joining us now to react to Kristen's
report Judicial Watch president tom
Fitton former Clinton pollster an
advisor Mark Penn author of the upcoming
book the Russia hoax the illicit scheme
to clear Hillary Clinton and frame
Donald Trump all right Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett all right guys I'm
gonna start with you Greg I mean you
know we're sending now this guy man
afford to jail claiming the judges
saying that he actually tried to tamper
with a couple of witnesses
why is he in jail on the rest of these
bozos not well that's a very good
question and the judge should be blaming
herself she is the one who failed to
issue a no-contact order with regard to
any witnesses and I've read through the
court documents
Andrew Weissman and Robert Muller's
evidence of this is incredibly scant and
cryptic it is enough to revoke bail
because that's an incredibly low
threshold right but they also were
charging him with obstruction of justice
in a superseding indictment that's
utterly preposterous given the evidence
look Greg look you and I both know that
for them to do this they indict them
they indict them again superseding
indictment they start threatening him
and now they throw him in jail they must
be desperate because this is a guy who's
charged with a crime that occurred 12
years ago that half the people in
Washington or lobbying should be in the
same lockup with him
what do they think he has on Trump he
only was with him for a few months they
know he has nothing on Trump but that
has never stopped prosecutors from
putting a document in front of somebody
that they're squeezing and say sign this
they don't care those prosecutors about
the rule of law and perjury
they suborn perjury by squeezing
witnesses all the time and that is a
crime all right tom Fitton you know
they're the the prosecutor in me and the
way I ran an office who wouldn't allow
that kind of thing but the feds are a
different breed of cat Tom your take on
this whole thing with Manafort being in
jail what
do you think they think he's gonna say
other than perjure himself you know look
at the anti-corruption watchdog and me
suggest this is all this is retaliation
by the Moller team for mana forts
pushing back against his authority yeah
I think it's overkill and I think the
mower operation recognizes that mana
Ford is its reason for being there
really is no Muller investigation to
speak of substantively without this big
Matta for indictment these multiple
indictments now you shut down the mana
Ford investigation and really everything
kind of flitters away because the Trump
investigation is going nowhere there is
no Russia collusion and again it's a
nice distraction from that IG report
that confirms the mauler operation was
generated as a result of these crooked
FBI agents who were hated Donald Trump
who set this thing in motion and we're
working for Muller for a good period of
time frankly the whole thing has been
tainted I'm thinking back to the
Whitehurst scandal with the FBI labs
throughout all the cases these folks
were involved tree but you know what's
amazing to me Tom and you're the one and
then I've always given so much credit to
for before through your for your freedom
of information but you know now we find
out why was this text never given to
Congress the one where he says you know
you were gonna stop it he's not gonna be
President is he no we're gonna stop it
maybe somebody's gotta pay for not
giving that to Congress you know when
you can't plan the Obama Justice
Department for that judge it's this
Justice Department this FBI that's been
covering up all these text messages are
these emails they're fighting us in
court right now on every scandal issue
the IG is raised
yep they haven't given us one text
message they haven't given us the McCabe
text messages yep they're holding back
information about DOJ collusion during
the Obama administration with the
Clinton campaign this Justice Department
not the Obama Justice Department all
right so mark Penn I mean what as you
listen to this and and what tom Fitton
says is absolutely the case if this is
the Republican Justice Department well
but it's real
stay done to itself I think what's
happened here with the recusal and the
independent counsel and rod Rosenstein
is that they're not accountable to
Congress they can't be fired by the
president they've they've kind of come
in and created a government of their own
here which we thought when we got rid of
the Independent Counsel statute could no
longer here's a bill went and absolutely
and and look you see what's happening
with mana for it I mean you look
Weinstein is out on a million dollar
bail Harvey Weinstein right right
Madoff ten million dollar bail now now
tell me what league is mana for in the
judge here is in cahoots with the
independent counsel to pressure mana for
it to the limit because he's the only
guy pleading not guilty you know I got
to tell you something mark I mean that
obviously is very interesting but as the
public has watched this whole thing
proceeded who would think of mana for
turned on the president now but anything
you said at any truth to it given the
fact that they've been squeezing them
for a year but I'm gonna go to you bring
on this whole thing with the FBI now
right now Horowitz is going to testify
on Monday he's gonna try to maybe you
know explain why in spite of these
prejudices statements the report and the
actions were not sufficient to call for
a criminal charge against anyone what he
needs to say is look I couldn't prove
that they're bias influence decisions I
couldn't prove it great right I got to
show you this this is proof it's called
500 pages it is a compendium of bias if
you will but the Horowitz said look did
it influence the decision to clear
Hillary Clinton I can't prove it through
testimonial or documentary error well of
course she can't nobody puts their
crimes in writing nobody confesses to
Horowitz we did it for political reasons
and obstructed this is crazy tom Fitton
I tried a lot of murder cases with
absolutely no eyewitness testimony it's
called circumstantial evidence this is
more than circumstantial this is what
people are saying they are describing
what they're
State of Mind is well you know
unfortunately the Inspector General's a
typical government bureaucrat he sees he
set of facts that everything that
Hillary Clinton did all these decisions
that the prosecutors made and the FBI
made that fell down in her favor and
helped protect her they all were
perfectly defensible and he couldn't
second-guess them you know look I don't
buy any of that people should read the
report themselves and they're gonna see
a Clinton email investigation that was a
sham that should be reopened and a
Russia investigation irredeemably
tainted by this anti-trump bias I just
can't believe we're still talking about
a molar investigation after Peters after
mr. struck said his goal was the South
Trump right mark and last question to
you what happens to Jim Comey's book a
higher loyalty now well look I hope
sales are cut off I mean the whole way
he has acted here in defiance really
when you look at it now he was in
defiance of everyone when he was FBI
director so you expect him to be in
defiance of everybody now that he's a
private citizen look I have thought and
I wrote a piece of the in the hill a
higher disloyalty I think that he really
you know the brought down the FBI that's
clear to me that Hillary was a winner in
this report because home they said all
the actions were reasonable I think
Trump was a winner because the struck
tasks really show the anti-trump animus
and I think Co Meath and the FBI were
losers they didn't operate in a even
remotely professional way right
gentleman was gonna be destroyed by this
which I ran out and got the book done 10
times up